what made what inspired you to stop the
drugs
my son having having your son well my
son is
is what made me completely stop but i
had been saying it for
like we down them last few months like
we was
like tour was tour was so hardcore it
was like every day i was high off
cocaine
and you know i would wake up drink a
beer
make a drink you know snort some lines
and hit the stage
you know it was like it was a repetitive
thing it was it was how i was being
because i'm not a social person
that's you know like that especially
when it's you know
a lot going on or whatever but i don't
know man
it was just you you felt it getting out
of control i felt
like i would even say it to the homies
and they'll just be like nah you're
playing because i was the biggest cook
and it was like no you're playing
well i literally down to that end like
the last few months
i was i would snort coke and be like i
don't like how i feel
like i'm just tired of this feeling you
know
like whatever i started becoming i was
more so because i used to just do it
when i was in the studio and be creative
and it was to be creative and then at
the end it just was i would just find
myself doing it
you know and going out and let's let's
let's let's find the blow
you feel me let's figure it out man we
just be partying
honestly when we came to la i feel like
that's how we build our connections
everybody knew we had cocaine they're
like yup
they party oh i met everyone
in l.a off of coco that's crazy
was there ever a point in time where you
had like any sort of scares with the
[ __ ] like where you thought you might
have taken too much
hell yeah like when you're like freaking
out like [ __ ] i might be oding
and this was the craziest part like i
remember one time
in columbus like like years ago
i was at my homies mom's crib and we
were all just doing coke or whatever
and um bro we i was with my
my other homie bro he came through with
some pure [ __ ] and we just kept going
crazy going crazy and
i'm trying to keep up my little ass you
feeling everybody else bigger and [ __ ]
i'm like man
my body can't take this [ __ ] it i i felt
like my
my body froze up so i went out of the
room
and like laid on the couch and and i
just felt like
i didn't even have no body but i swear
to god in my heart but
i just felt my heart it was just
i'm like bro [ __ ] and and every time
i'll be like i'm not doing that again
and i'll do it again damn
that [ __ ] is like it's great that's why
i'm saying at first it's the best thing
ever but when when then the fun part is
over
and it becomes like the the real
addictive thing
like you said you started doing it in
the studio and then
it was like you were just doing it to do
it and that's what sucks you feel me and
and i
i'm and first in an instance i made it
cool too
to my fans mm-hmm and that's the how
many hey when you're on the road how
many times fans just
throw your bags a blow see and that's
another bad thing all the time
all the time and then you don't know
what kind of you don't know how pure
this [ __ ] is you don't know what it's
pressed with
well i could have died so many times
just off of bad drugs
you know we hear this story every day
you know
i'm cool on trying to you know worry
about if
i'm gonna be alive i told you i'm going
home to my son facts
that's it that's a beautiful thing
that's it